everything that I had been taught versus
everything that I experienced when I was
actually in the other realm was totally
opposite the first thing I I started to
wonder is why didn't I know this when I
was born and what came to me was that I
did know this when I was born you did I
did know it but it was conditioned out
of me so
so one of the things that I realized
when I was on the other side a what I
would call one of I like to call it a
universal truth but usually when I speak
about it I tell people it's my truth
because sometimes people don't like to
hear that that you're espousing a truth
for everybody so I tend to say this is
my truth and it works for me
um and so one of them is that that you
really really do have to
um love and value yourself first above
and before anyone else and this is a
tough one for many people especially
people who are empaths and this was a
really hard one for me but it's
interesting because if you are somebody
who is an empath if you are somebody who
does feel sensitive towards other people
and you feel sensitive towards the
planet and you want to go out there and
be in the front lines and help people
you tell and to be the kind of person
that puts yourself last and that was me
and that was exactly me but that is what
led to my downfall that is what led to
me being sick that's what led to the
cancer if you want to make a difference
in the world because we are all
connected we are all energy first we are
Spirit first physical second so the more
expanded
um and the more fulfilled your energy is
the more that your physical body can can
Thrive and live happier healthier and
fulfill its purpose here on Earth and
the more you can uplift other people if
if we are all connected and my energy is
high I'm automatically lifting the hole
Yeah and since we're all connected if I
am a doormat if I'm downtrodden if I'm
depleted and I'm on the verge of getting
sick I'm bringing down the whole
so that was the that was the biggest
universal truth I learned that your
energy matters my energy matters because
we're all connected so my self-love my
worth my value my ability to find joy in
my life actually matters to the whole
and that was something that we're never
taught I never knew before I was taught
the opposite that I had to give and give
of myself and almost be a martyr and
what I didn't realize is that by doing
that and depleting myself I'm actually
Bringing Down the whole because there's
such a difference between
thinking something and feeling something
can you articulate that difference I I I
mean in my own experience even actually
like if I reflect back on that story
with that dog and my experience in on
the beach was that like something simple
when I wanted to see the dog I couldn't
it wouldn't show up and then as soon as
I let go but not mentally let go of
course that's part of it but when I
physically like emotionally in my body
let go of it and I was like it's fine
all of a sudden the dog would appear it
was like magic obviously I got a lot of
information on this trip but like that
that was that was an example of Letting
Go and and feeling it and so I've also
done manifested manifesting techniques
and meditations where you go into what
is what it is that you want you think
about why but then you also embody the
elevated emotions having accomplished or
done it
um and and truly it's magical when you
do it things happen things can happen so
quickly sometimes they don't but but it
can and so there's just a difference
between the actual feeling and I I kind
of think this is what works with people
too is there's such a disconnect between
what comes out of someone's mouth and
how they actually feel and that's why a
song or a message or something can just
like hit home versus
sort of roll off of you is because
there's a frequency with truth that's
happening so like why is that what's
going on that we have to like we have to
actually feel it what what is what's
happening why is that the magic sauce
that is the magic sauce so there's a big
difference between thinking something
and feeling something a huge difference
um so we can stuff our brains with
information but it won't really have an
effect I mean it's like going to school
you go to school and you fill your
brains with all this information but
it's not going to have an impact in the
world until something pulls at your
heart so the way I describe it in the
language I use is the heart is the
connection to your soul your heart tells
you why your soul came here what it
wanted to express and but your head is
so your heart is connected to you to the
other realm to your soul your head is
connected to this Physical Realm your
head is where you need to store the
tools to help you navigate on how to get
from A to B but your heart is the one
with the vision because your soul came
here with an intention of something to
fulfill and your soul kind of already
knows the intention that it came with
even though you always have free will
you have the free will to follow your
purpose or not or to follow your Soul's
Calling or not
um I like to use the term calling
because it's almost like your future
self calling you towards it yeah and yet
we always have the choice as to whether
to follow that or not
um and so when you know that when you're
when you're listening to your heart when
you get the when you get chills or when
you get those aha moments so you could
be listening to a podcast or something
and it's just going in your head and
it's just going in your head but the
minute you get that oh and you and you
want to rewind that bit and you want to
play it again because it just it it gave
you an aha moment something dropped like
when you say the penny dropped for me it
means it dropped from your head to your
heart now you feel it once you feel it
you can't unfeel it it means it's there
it's embedded in your body to me
you have to look out for those aha
moments and what those aha moments are
telling you it's your Soul's way of
communicating with you so it's your
Soul's way of saying that that that is
part of your mission that so so whenever
you feel that aha or you feel the chills
or you feel and I know that anybody
listening would know what I'm talking
about it's like you can be listening to
something and something Suddenly It's
like whoa I get that
um so that is your Soul's way of
communicating with you I also love the
sort of more proactive side of it which
is calling it in like you said it's
calling to the Future and so when you
can let yourself go there which includes
things like needing self-love self-worth
because you have to actually believe you
deserve it to be able to generate the
feeling like you have to kind of that's
I because that ends up being one of the
hardest parts is like truly viscerally
embodying the feeling of gratitude or
seeing what you want or having what you
want
um excitement gratitude any of those
things are hard to access because like
cognitively or Pro or whatever get got
programmed as in childhood says you
don't deserve that you shouldn't have
that you're not worthy of that
um and and so it like serves as like
these like this maze to get through so
that you can embody that feeling because
it's just it's such a powerful tool you
had mentioned
um talking about sort of lives and you
know what she came here for and like
what about con Soul contracts
reincarnation how much of life is Free
Will versus determinism interestingly in
the other realm time doesn't feel linear
and it feels compressed so I was aware
of I I was aware of certain
um what I would just call Milestones
like I didn't I didn't see my entire
future unfold before me because we
always have free will to go on a
different path or to not follow what our
Soul's Calling is you know like you
think linear and you think that of
course I take the lessons I learned in
this lifetime to the next one and Karma
plays out and if I did this bad thing in
this life I have to repay it in that
life it doesn't work that way on that
side Karma doesn't exist from One Life
to another well karma is something like
over here it's like you know we use
expressions like karma's a [ __ ] and and
we kind of say that what goes around
comes around it does within this
lifetime but just like when you cross
over and you realize there's nothing to
forgive even though while you're here
people do feel that that oh this person
really really hurt me and it would be
hard to move on before I forgive them
for it and so on but on the other side
you you totally get why they did what
they did it's the same with with even
Karma it's like oh I wouldn't have done
that if I knew this or oh I was set up
you know like the life I was living led
me to doing this the karma gets
completely erased and then you kind of
work on what's the next experience you
want to have and it doesn't mean that if
you were a criminal in this life that
that you're going to that that you're
going to have an awful life next life
you may actually even get to experience
the complete opposite and realize wow
this is what it's like to have a blessed
life that's you know I don't need to be
a criminal you believe in reincarnation
I do we believe absolutely that we have
multiple lives yes we do and we get to
experience different things okay so
what's the point of reincarnation I
always wanted was under the impression
it was all about sort of your Soul's
Evolution and growth and that you had to
end up sort of making your way through
life's lessons
um to achieve a certain sort of
frequency to not have to come back to
this reality
which is a lot of Duality and suffering
and pain so although that is somewhat
true as a whole
as a whole we are evolving as the idea
is to evolve all of us as a whole if you
think about it like you could even have
somebody who is so involved to even
actually choose to come back
as a criminal
to give the planet an opportunity
to
um for example as an example to even
change a system a change a system of
justice or change the criminal system
somebody could actually be so evolved
it's like I know this is an illusion I
know that I'm going to be fine so I'm
going to allow myself to actually take
the fall for something go to jail be a
criminal be beaten up you know they
could actually choose to do that from an
evolved space and you don't always know
what the person's actual trajectory is
so can you choose to not reincarnate yes
you can actually you can choose to not
reincarnate what else could you be are
you ever I don't know if you believe in
extraterrestrials or other other beings
in the universe or is it just a source
Consciousness like what else could you
be if you didn't want to be a human I do
believe that we can be other forms of
Consciousness and exist on other planes
um and those other planes could even be
other planets that could be existing as
on other planets beyond the Galaxy I do
believe there's a lot out there that
still that we don't know yet for sure if
you like this clip and you want to hear
the whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen